[Music]
we chose IBM because of first and
foremost security and then scalability
availability agility and reliability all
of those are there we were very leery on
a lot of the clouds to which one to use
when IBM decided to put Z on the cloud
it made absolutely perfect sense to us
since we already know how secure it is
we have to protect our own intellectual
property all of our user data and we
have all of our authors intellectual
property with their stories that we need
to protect and the IBM hyper protect
offers us that and succeeds and actually
does what it says it's going to do our
users need to be authenticated and they
need to be validated that the number of
sessions that there have going are the
correct number that they're paying for
and we use an app ID and a token system
in order to give the authentications and
keep everybody's numbers in order we
also need to happen now we can't wait
six months to put in a new machine and
with the IBM cloud we don't have to we
call up IBM and say we need to expand
here and for how much and they are able
to get stuff up and running in less than
a day it was 27 hours from the time we
said go and to the time it was up and
running 11 websites 23 databases 22
million lines of code 15 terabytes of
data one of the biggest benefits is that
we don't have to have a data center we
had billions of data points to tell us
IBM works and the IBM cloud was the
solution for us it does what it's
supposed to do
[Music]